yesterday's news though and and i'm not
gonna
i'm not gonna do the i told you so i
didn't need to tell anybody this this
was an
obvious and evident reality of
what the nfl players association has
been recommending
to players this year as it relates to
working out on their own versus working
out
at the team facility yeah i've said it
time and again
work out at the team facility you get
free insurance
as it relates to your salary for the
coming year
minimum minimum free insurance
so if you suffer some sort of a freak
injury
and with that many guys in the nfl
they're going to happen somebody's going
to i know that
we individually think it's not going to
be us that's one of the defects i think
of our genetic makeup
it's going to happen and when it happens
it's going to be costly and it's
especially costly in a year when the
nflpa has made a fight over
this issue of guys not showing up to
work out at the facility because if a
guy does get injured away
from the facility while he's working out
to make himself
as prepared as he can be for the season
teams are going to say sorry
sucks for you you're not getting paid
and juwan james
broncos tackle who opted out last year
gave up 10 million dollars in fully
guaranteed compensation they got bumped
to this year yeah so it was still fully
guaranteed
right broncos were still on the hook for
it now they're not
because he tore an achilles tendon away
from the team facility proving the point
in an interesting way for juwan james
yeah get your asses to the facility guys
at a minimum at a minimum
at a minimum talk to your agents and
find out what it would cost you
if the same thing happens to you because
you now have a tangible example you can
point to
and say hey agent what is this going to
cost me and my family
if i choose to go down to planet fitness
today
versus going to the team facility today
tell me what it's going to cost
if i have that freak fluke
can't happen to me but we see that it
happens type of an injury
that that's the message that all players
out there
need to heed and act upon find out what
it would cost you
if that injury happens away from the
team headquarters
well the next thing i want to say i mean
you're right on everything
a hundred percent do you think the
broncos are going to do it though
yes you don't pay them they're not
they're not paying them okay
all right so i don't know that for sure
i've heard enough i've heard look you've
heard enough
get injured yeah they're not happy the
guy get injured right but they're happy
that they can avoid this 10 million
dollars right they moved on
they moved on he opted out they moved on
look
we we've fully and completely supported
the guys who opted out last year there
was so much uncertainty and nobody knew
what was going on
the bottom line is this if you stay away
and the nfl reminded all teams last
month
you stay away you get injured away from
the facility
you don't get paid now it's up to the
team yeah and sometimes the team will
pay
right corral suggs right popped an
achilles playing basketball yes
they paid him i've had others who was it
yeah there's others
we we talked to a general manager about
this
it was the flip side of the patrick
mahomes
and the chiefs telling him stop playing
basketball there was video of somebody
else playing basketball they said go
ahead you can't remember
right and then they're like yeah yeah we
want our guys to go they know the limits
right they know how far they can go
right they know what they can do
and if you do get injured they'll
support you now it's different if you do
that in january february when
everything's shut down
you're out playing basketball instead of
choosing to show up at the team facility
that's when they're going to get you
so they're not going to pay juwan james
it's 10 million dollars this year
it goes beyond that it goes beyond that
it's going to cost him more than that
but i'll tell you that in a second yeah
well i was just gonna say i mean you
know i wouldn't expect them to i mean
again i know this is a little bit of a
civil war that's going on in the nfl the
coaches want the players there i mean
there's no doubt about that you know
they might say hey it's
it's voluntary and all those type of
things but gosh mike you talk to enough
gm's and coaches
i do too you know i mean it's come up a
few times in conversation
already this offseason with with friends
i have in the league
i mean of course they want the players
there yeah it's voluntary they're going
to say all the positive things they want
but you know they they feel like the
guys that are not there at the facility
are doing the team and
injustice and you know a lot of the
times the coaches care about these
players they want to make them
better too they realize they might not
work the way they need to work
unless they got you know somebody
looking over their shoulder a little bit
but this is where you know it's a
slippery slope
like hey with juwan james okay he opted
out
you know he might be at the point of his
career where you're like i don't know if
he's worth all this money
all those type of things it's easy to
cut the cord maybe on that type of
decision there
and easy to get away with in the locker
room but the only thing i'll say mike is
just as far as teams and maybe having to
pump the brakes a little bit
is like the scenarios we've seen a
little bit like a terrell
suggs what if it's a star of your team
one of those big
time players are they really going to
take away the contract
and everything like that that's where i
think the teams are going to have to be
at least thoughtful or a little bit
careful as they go down this path
i agree with you it's a case-by-case
situation team by team
and i think it's important for the
player
to understand and to have an assessment
an objective
neutral assessment that's what it is
through his agent right what risk am i
at right if if i don't show up
yeah and i blow out an achilles down at
planet fitness
what are they going to do to me and if
juwan james had gone through that
analysis based upon the fact that he was
underwhelming in the first year of his
four-year contract that paid him a 12
million
bonus right a bunch of other guaranteed
money that he opted out last year so you
already have a little bit of a scarlet
letter even though you shouldn't
do you love football yeah do you really
love football are you all in you walked
away from 10 million dollars last year
you didn't trust us to take care of you
are you kidding me
and you throw on top of that that 10
million carries over this year
uh yeah you're you're you're at risk
of the team saying we're not paying you
and
maybe there will be another guy out
there who is a star player
and it would be politically delicate
in the locker room for the team to say
yeah sorry we're not paying you
but juwan james is on the we're not
paying you side of the equation
miles garrett's the guy that we saw
playing basketball
that's right kevin stefanski the browns
coach who told me
i've told him this i've told all our
players listen you got to stay in shape
you need to do some things that get your
cardio going
you got to do it safely he's very well
aware of that and i marvel at his
athleticism that was stefanski in early
march
just a week or so after that video of
the incredible hulk playing basketball
get out of his way so
i don't think he gets injured playing
basketball i think he dishes out
injuries playing basketball if you're
anyone else from the browns don't play
basketball with miles garrett maybe that
would be the message from kevin
stevansky
but now that we're in the window yeah
where you can show up for work
it's voluntary okay fine keep thinking
that you can show up for work
you can make your coach happy you can
make the team happy
and more importantly than anything else
you protect yourself
and your family against the worst case
scenario and
i get criticized all the time
for worrying too much about the worst
case scenario
when you practice law when you are
engaged in litigation
everything you do is a direct result
of some worst case scenario
happening that's why people get sued
something unexpected something bad
something costly has occurred you live
your life
digging into the facts rebuilding what
happened
applying the law to it and either trying
to find a way to get justice for someone
who thinks they were wrong
or defend someone who's accused of doing
the wrongdoing
but it all flows from something bad
happening
right so it conditions you to think and
plan
and prepare and avoid bad things
happening it's very easy here
i say this to any and all players who
are out there watching the show all
three of you
and that may be on the high side of the
over under
get to the facility and protect
your salary and if you have any doubts
talk to your agent
and find out whether or not your agent
agrees with our assessment
number one you're protecting your salary
the other thing for juwan james
that guarantee is now avoided it's not
like well okay he'll get his 10 million
next year
they can void the guarantee because of
the injury that happened away from the
facility they can cut him and not owe
him another penny
that 10 million gone forever right 5
million in injury guarantee for next
year
gone forever and you know what they can
do they can ask the cba last night
signing bonus
signing bonus money three million right
i figured i somebody told me you could
get
nine million that he'd have to forfeit
because he got 12 and he's earned three
and he's got nine left i think it's
three because it goes
one year at a time if they keep him on
the roster next year and he plays
then he earns the three million for next
year
right from his signing bonus this year's
three million in jeopardy so that's 13
million dollars
that he's going to be out and he's not
going to have the chance to earn it
next year i predict they'll avoid the
guarantees
they'll cut him eventually and that's
going to be that for juwan james
perhaps in the nfl and that money that
he did
he had it it was there yeah fully
guaranteed
skill injury cap all you gotta do is
show up and work right
and you go down to wherever he was pop
the achilles
fluke injury can't happen to me happens
to you and that money
is gone forever extreme example
but it proves the point it proves the
point guys at a time when the union
leadership
the player leadership i think the
non-player leadership is kind of like
hey knock yourselves out guys you know
better than we do you're the guys who
are the players you know when you can
and can't work out and where you can and
can't get injured but you know sometimes
you're wrong
they're putting pressure on the rookies
and the undrafted guys did not show up
now are you kidding me
beyond the fact that they you know they
they
need a place where they can go and have
that financial insurance
in the event of injury they got to make
the team
so i i don't get it i don't know what
they're going to want to prove
and you and i always support the players
we always support the union we look for
the way to say
hey wait a minute why are we always
siding with the billionaires maybe
there's some merit on the other side of
this
i don't see the merit and it was proven
to us yesterday no well
what like what we're doing here is it
might seem like we're siding with the
billionaires but we're we're still
siding with the players protected we're
exactly right we're still trying to
we're on the side of the players here
we're going it's it's a bad
it's a bad way to do things it's a bad
way to do business it's not helping you
out players and this is like this is the
perfect example the perfect type of
player
that a team and the nfl i believe will
like you've been saying mike that's
going to want to make an example of this
situation
you know this is shock fired across the
bow whatever
flares in the air warning flares in the
air to guys that are gonna be in similar
situations now to where
hey if the broncos do do what we think
they are
that it's gonna you know perk up other
guys who are in certain situations like
juwan james and go wait what
what am i doing why am i working out at
some
personal gym you know down here by my
hometown
and risking everything you know by not
being at the facility where
yeah your insurance you know you're
getting coached
everything like that they're taking
always the well-being of the player
at hand because they know there's a
great investment in that player for the
most times and like you said it
when you're in the window of like it's
workouts
they want you there at the facility it'd
be one thing if you hurt your achilles
or your ankle like you said back
in january or february that's fine you
know
teams will be kind of be like well at
least he was out trying to stay in shape
and do it that's a good thing
but now it's looked as a negative and uh
yeah the the broncos are in a tough spot
you know because they got a position to
fill now they i'm sure they're probably
looking at going damn i wish this would
have happened before the draft so we
could have maybe drafted a tackle
but i i'm with you mike i think they're
going to make an example of him and
this might open some eyes with other
players in the league
they could also say i wish it would have
happened before tuesday yeah
they could have tried to sign alejandro
villanueva before he signed with the
ravens
no doubt that in a second right but with
mike munchek the former steelers
offensive line coach in denver
would have been an easy replacement now
they got by without juwan james last
year but when you give that guy
the contract they gave him in 2019 you
want him to be there you want him to
earn it especially when
you owe him 10 million right of course
you're going to do everything you can to
put them in the lineup you're not going
to have them stand on the sidelines and
make 10 million dollars
now they get the best case scenario
despite the fact that no team wants to
see a player get
get injured they they they in a year
where the salary cap
is tight down 25 million from where we
thought it would be but for the pandemic
they had 10 million dollars falling out
of the sky which
could ultimately be very convenient when
the time comes to absorb
a certain 14.7 million dollar base
salary that a certain quarterback has
who may end up being traded to the
denver broncos at some point they'll
need a right tackle to protect him
but they just picked up 10 million
dollars in cash and cap space they can
use to make the transaction work chris
yeah no i mean you're right there's no
doubt about it there's a little wiggle
room but i do think this is like a
little bit of an issue for their
football team in general
you know they last year they demar
dodson they signed him i don't know how
they feel about some of the younger guys
on their roster to fill
fill the role here that's going to be
the big thing to watch going forward i
mean they're a little thin at the
position
you know they got a guy quinn bailey
from arizona state who just got done
with his rookie year
so i mean is he a guy that they looked
at to take over that type of spot so
they're definitely gonna have to dive
into free agency here
and see what's left over you know and
can they get lucky in
maybe a mitchell schwartz can he get
healthy enough to where they sign him
something like that but uh this is a
team that's got a high octane offense
and there's definitely a little issue
here right now at right tackle eric
fisher visited the colts this week he
becomes a possible other one well put
him on the right side if
he's available if i recall correctly he
played some right tackle earlier
i think you're right he did develop as a
left tackle you know it took him a while
to get going and he finally did get
going so that would be another
possibility definitely but yeah
villanueva
a guy that muncheck knows very well a
guy that muncheck made into
the player that he was in pittsburgh one
day earlier
they would have had him so look i i
i again this isn't i told you so
it is i shouldn't had to tell you we
shouldn't had to see this this shouldn't
had to happen
this shouldn't have occurred this
vendetta
this saltiness this whatever it is oh
we're upset because you ram 17 games
down our throats oh we're upset because
we don't get more money whatever it is
we're all we we want no off season
program because that protects
veterans jobs and even though jc treader
the president of the union has said
that's ridiculous it's not ridiculous of
course
if you don't give the young guys a
chance to perform
they're not going to be as ready to
compete when training camp rolls around
all these things you got to make an
individual decision
and juwan james is now the guy
that agents can point to to say to their
clients stop listening
to what the union's trying to tell you
don't they realize how they are if they
keep pushing this
undermining faith in the union if you
have your union
that is supposedly looking out for
everyone sending a message
that actually jeopardizes millions of
dollars
in player salary and potentially puts
them in a position where they have to
pay back signing bonus money
yeah how are you supposed to have faith
in that organization i i'm with you
stop it now yeah it shows you the
selfish of the veteran players once
again
it's it's about that that's the problem
they need to issue a memo today saying
we were wrong
yeah in light of what happened with
juwan james we were wrong they won't do
it
but they need to come out and say we
were wrong get your ass to work
and protect your salary protect yourself
protect your family
we were wrong we're sorry we forget that
whole thing we'll find another way to
push back
against owners who always have extra
leverage against us because we won't
strike
but they'll lock out and they'll not bat
an eye
if we miss a full season and we just
have to deal with that coming up with a
fight
that was completely unnecessary and
gratuitous and harmful to juwan james
now i don't know that he specifically
wasn't there because of this nflpa
directive
regardless they should be telling these
guys
you need to be there this is free
insurance
the worst case scenario happens you get
your money why would you not want to be
right this astounds me chris i i know
mike
i mean yeah i mean it's it's it's a bad
message from the nflpa mike kliss by the
way from denver he's reporting that's
why he stayed away
for juwan james well and he's a guy that
covet opted out
you know had a covert opt-out too and
you know there was kind of some wrong
messaging in my opinion too with that
from the nfl pa startup that it wasn't a
safe environment and all those type of
things
so yes uh i if i was a player i would
certainly be looking out at the corner
of my eye right now about the leadership
from the nflpa what the hell they're
telling guys to do
and yeah it's cool if you're a veteran
player to stay away right now but you
better be like a damn good player
star of the football team one of the
better players at your position in the
league
j.c tretter is that he's the guy that he
doesn't have to worry about that
he's really awesome he's one of the
better centers in football
he's made a ton of money and that's to
me where he's getting lost a little
here with the greater good of all the
other players uh and that's no
disrespect to jc treader i got a lot of
respect for him as a player and what he
does
i know it's not easy but it's really
only the star players
the top three or four or five guys on
the team that are gonna be able to get
away with this i think going forward
where if they got hurt okay they might
not hold their feet to the fire and tell
them they're
not gonna get their money everything
like that but the middle class the lower
class
i'm sorry i just think that you know to
your point what you've been saying all
along
they're going to get made examples of
here as we go forward because teams want
these players back in the facility
and if we didn't care about players and
the money that they're due to make
and the families that they have to
support we would be saying ah it's no
big deal it's a fluke
uh it ain't gonna happen look that's a a
million to one shot
okay oh and and you know what if he
hadn't opted out last year maybe his
achilles wouldn't have popped maybe he'd
have been in better shape i mean that's
the stuff we'd be saying
not use this as your wake-up call use
this as the shot across the bow
use this as the thing that convinces you
that the right place for you to be if
you're going to be exerting yourself
physically in any way shape or form
is in the team facility and mike kliss
of 9 news in denver
reported yesterday that juwan james had
been working out at the team's facility
until he decided to honor the nflpa
recommendation to stay away
now i don't know that that's 100
accurate but i know this
cliff didn't get that from juwan james
cliff's got that from the broncos
and that gives you an insight into the
attitude that broncos are going to have
about this they're going to be
following yeah what the league has
suggested which is
you get one of these guys that decides
he's going to stay away because the
union wants him to and he gets injured
oh that's going to piss him off even
more sorry liverpool
but yeah that's going to piss him off
even more sorry manchester
the fact that they were there and then
they they left because of that
that that's that's going to be even more
annoying to the organization and they're
like
yeah because like what you said you you
opted out hey they're going to be like
hey
grady's back in the building let's you
know we gotta we get to mold the clay a
little bit here before the
training camp starts and get them ready
to go once again wait what you're
leaving
why because the nfl pa what okay all
right man good luck
make sure you keep working out and
staying in touch you know but yeah that
bye see you later and they walk in the
other room with the other coaches and
they're going
damn juan james gonna leave and listen
to the damn nflpa
you believe this crap i mean that's
what's going on behind the behind closed
doors there
in the nfl with these type of
conversations the
coaches are laughing it's a joke they're
angry
they're pissed off it makes no sense it
doesn't and the coaches aren't doing it
from the standpoint of like oh we're
looking at these guys like a piece of
meat
they're looking at it like hey yeah we
want to get better as a team but they're
going to make these guys better by
being there and all of that um but the
other thing mike and i just gonna
go to it if you don't mind like we got
the other side of the story with quinn
and williams
where it's the perfect thing that could
have happened yesterday from apples to
oranges to say look here's one that's
not a story
because it's done the right way and
there's no worries that this guy has
after an injury
yeah foot injury suffered by quinton
williams the jets defensive lineman
a top five draft pick a couple of years
ago he is reportedly out until training
camp
with a foot injury now not out for the
season
so it not a big deal right from that
perspective
but but still the injury and the
potential fallout
it's all covered by his salary he
doesn't jeopardize his guarantee see
here's what happens
if you've got a fully guaranteed salary
and quentin williams because of his
draft status does
you get that injury away from the
facility the moment that you are unable
to practice for a mandatory event
mandatory mini camp that would trigger
it right guarantees void
so if you're not a great player even if
you're fully healthy
when week one rolls around or when
training camp rolls around
they've voided your guarantees you're
gone it's over
you're cut we don't owe you anything see
that's a problem for juwan james the p.s
to the story was
he may not be out for the full season
depending upon what they find during
surgery right it's not going to save the
10 million
10 million is gone he'll be cut before
he's back by the end of the season he
can play for somebody else
right but i think the broncos are that's
it
fourth guarantee cut from the roster see
you later 10 million dollars that's that
yeah i i i think you're probably right
mike i mean it's it's going to be
kind of interesting to watch it go down
uh because it's it's not
it's not going to be popular within the
locker room it's not
but i think these are tough decisions
that teams are going to make to
to make an example no doubt about it and
yeah quinn and williams
doing things the right way yeah you're
right it mike is not you're right it's
mandatory things
it's you know again a guy like quinn
williams
if he was bothered and then it did leak
into the season of him not being a
hundred percent and all of those type of
things there's
a lot of issues you could have even if
you did get a 10-week injury here
you know away from the facility and and
if it doesn't get back to like you said
hitting on all cylinders ready to go to
practice on mandatory events and play
football
you're in deep crap you're in deep crap
and that's where these players got to
really think twice about what they're
doing
and you mentioned the coaches are the
ones who want the guys there this is a
point we made when this issue first came
up
the owners don't care you're trying to
put pressure on the owners
they don't care it's not costing them
any money if these guys stay away
cost them less have a facility yeah they
don't have to pay the per diem yeah they
don't have to pay all the food and
feeding everybody and everything it's a
way
it's a huge cost cut for them well i
think about this the young guys the
rookies the undrafted guys what do they
do they put them up in a hotel room
to find an apartment they don't have to
find a place to live it's free room and
board
for the young guys who are being
pressured or at least were being
pressured as a monday
to not show up for the off-season
program
so they would show solidarity and
brotherhood and you know not go in and
impress the coaches and have them maybe
decide to keep those undrafted guys in
late round
draft picks instead of veteran players
who could be cut and save a bunch of
money so
the owners never cared about this if
anything hey
the owner of the broncos and there isn't
one now the trustees who run the broncos
picked up 10 million dollars and
now can get away from a guy that they
probably wish they hadn't signed to a
four-year 51 million dollar deal back in
2019 yeah that's right
it's actually a win right for the
broncos organization
and it's a win for the league because it
does allow
and i don't know how many shows are
going to be talking about it this way in
this kind of blunt terminology but
that this this is the message to the
players
out there and and i'm not going to say
take it from us
show up for work take it from us
talk to your agents that's right about
what you may lose
if you do have the juwan james injury
down at planet fitness or working out in
your backyard
or you know down in somebody's basement
with the
weight set that they bought at sears 20
years ago just
ask your agent what it is that you're
risking if that happens that that's
that's the message
because i just wonder whether those
conversations ever happened if they did
between juwan james and his agent i
think he would have been at the facility
yeah i would think so too
i i would you know it's it's it's it's
tough for the players
it's tough because you are stuck in the
crossroads of you want to support
players
and i'm sure as an offensive line group
and things like that
in the denver locker room there was
probably conversation and they decided
to band together and
you know hey we won't do this we're not
going to be here and do all those type
of things but
you know from everything you've said i
think you're spot on as
far as your advice to the players and
that's what i would say to the players
too this is one where
yeah i know you want to support and be a
team guy and everything like that
you got to be selfish here not
everybody's contracts the same way
not everybody's status on the on their
rosters the same way
and you gotta like you said what hey
agent
what does this mean for me not you know
not your other player who's got a 100
million dollar contract and is
definitely going to start
what about me middle class guy who's
going to have to fight for this position
or
not necessarily a star of the team and
uh that's where i think the
the player's got to go back to the
drawing board here
even though it's a union it's so
different from the normal union and i i
and and i don't know how normal or
abnormal it is but you know
we're not talking about a group of
workers at a facility who are all making
about the same amount of money and
they're all subject to the same
issues and concerns yeah it's not that
and risks right
it's very different it widely diverges
and ultimately
you got 90 guys working in each of the
32
shops right now and 37 of them aren't
going to be there
when the season rolls around that in and
of itself shows that there's a
difference
you've got guys yeah with guaranteed
money that may be jeopardized you got
all sorts of shapes and sizes
this blanket approach everyone stay away
but otherwise get yourself ready for the
season it it just
can't work it can't work it won't work
and it's not working especially not for
juwan
no no i know mike and the last thing i
wanted to say just i'm sorry i was going
to butt in there
just like like but that that part of it
too you know
there's there's only like a handful of
guys
and it's really the star players who
have had a really good career and
everything's gone
positive to where they buy into
everything nfl nfl is great because it's
been great to me and i've never been
hurt and i'm getting rich and i play and
this is awesome
the rest of the guys in the locker room
are pissed off in the nfl they feel like
they've gotten screwed over
teams have you know not been loyal to me
i haven't been paid what i deserve
you know i got injured and then they you
know devalued me and
so most of the most of the league is
like
anti-nfl to a degree as far as how
things are run and how they've been
treated there's very few
happy people in the locker room and
that's where you're right it's a totally
different
place than the normal union setting
where everybody's in the same boat and
everybody has the same circumstances
it's not that way and uh that's why i
think sometimes it's favored and tilted
towards those guys who are like
in the power position or the happiest or
like the nfl is great this is awesome
everything like that
uh and that's where there is a
disconnect there in the locker room
between all these guys
and there definitely is a point if
you've got general discontent about the
way you've been treated and the way that
the coaches regard you and the pressure
that gets put there's a point though
where you got to put that bag down
yeah and you got to get yourself ready
for the season yeah and you got to do it
in a way that protects
your income protects your family
protects
everything you care about financially
and if you work out on your own
you are putting yourself and your family
and your ability to pay your bills
and your ability to live the lifestyle
that you're currently living at
very real risk for what
for what for what if it is true that
juwan james
was working out at the facility and left
at the recommendation of the nflpa
what what did he really give up 10
million dollars for
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports